pour moi jean paul riopelle fait partie
de ces géants et les géants aux besoins
des espaces le premier ministre françois
legault a annoncé la création de
l'espace riopel le nouveau pavillon du
musée national des beaux-arts du québec
sera entièrement dédié aux oeuvres de
jean paul riopelle ce projet d'envergure
nécessite des investissements de plus de
40 millions de dollars l'artiste peintre
était déjà bien représenté aux mêmes bac
en 1967 nous avons organisé la première
grande rétrospective de l'artiste à être
présenté au québec un don historique
d'oeuvre d'une valeur de 100 millions de
dollars de la fondation
jean-paul-riopelle bonifiera le corpus
du mn bac ce soir qu'on lui dit déjà un
espace qui est tout petit à peine 400 m²
en une la collection la plus importante
au québec 447 oeuvres qui vont
s'enrichir de 68 ans major souvent des
grands formats afin de mettre en valeur
l'apport majeur de jean paul riopelle la
création de nouveaux lieux étaient
nécessaires j appelle c'est assurément
le plus grand artiste canadien c'est le
seul artiste canadien à ma connaissance
qui connu internationalement cercle des
artistes sont connaître nationalement
autre que riopel mairie avec ce nom qui
résonne dans le marché de l'art
international l'espace riopel sera situé
dans le pavillon central du musée avec
vue sur les plaines d'abraham et sur le
fleuve on ne crée un clin d'implantation
qui tirent parti de l'écosystème du
musée en fait on vous répond on voulait
pas recréer toutes les fonctions a déjà
tout ce qu il faut d accueil et des
réserves et ses dents quand on retire la
partie supérieure du pavillon central
qui est la verrière qui avait d'ailleurs
besoin d'énormément d'investissement
parce qu'elle coule le pavillon est
désuet le début des travaux est prévu
pour l'été 2023 à temps pour le 100e
anniversaire de naissance de riopelle le
nouveau pavillon ouvrira ses portes en
2025 ici tanya beaumont radio canada
québec